Donald Trump wants to bring back firing
squads possibly Guillotines and televise
executions according to a new report do
you believe that
this is a terrible
this is not good I think that he is
trying to course correct too much
because when he had that big
announcement about how he was going to
run again it was really it was perceived
as it was weak and this is not the Trump
that we knew in 2016. so now we're
talking about how he wants to execute
people on TV and and sell tickets to it
you know put it on pay-per-view I think
that he is off the rails yo we just want
you to be kind of a dick we don't want
you to go killing people you know what I
mean yeah it's like suddenly he's
duterte
correction of the 2016 Trump was perfect
yeah but this is I don't know what
happened I don't I don't know I think
that he tried to come back in in a more
vanilla way and I don't know who he
listened to but now he is trying to just
overly come back into what he was and it
just doesn't seem organic it seems this
seems like an SNL setup he has become a
caricature of himself it's a report I
don't know if I believe these people
it's just that they made it believable
you know does anyone know who's got
who's got Trump's ear now like who are
the people that are close to him that
are that would be advising him or even I
think Ivanka quit
yeah I don't have any idea and you know
in in defense too this seems ridiculous
even for him to a degree so no he was he
he asked if we could nuke a hurricane so
I've never heard of that before I'm not
so sure that this is all that
far-fetched against Donald Trump you
guys watch uh Yellowstone I don't yeah
yeah I've been watching Yellowstone
season three there's a spoiler alert for
those I didn't see it there's a uh a
scene where
this these uh this young these I think a
couple young girls get their horses
stolen they get beaten up pretty bad
and then one of the agents one of the
law enforcement guys calls the livestock
agents which is like the main
character's family and he's like we
gotta we gotta send a message
so they give the guys a nickel ride in
the back of uh of a horse trailer and it
kills them so they're trying to figure
out how to cover it up
so then one of the one of the main
characters who's the who's the livestock
commissioner he goes to the father of
this little girl
and he says you know like hey we brought
we're bringing back your trailer it's
like oh they said they couldn't bring it
back and he's like well we're going to
bring it back because you can't you know
Barrel Race without you know your your
trailer whatever and it's like thank you
then he asks the father what happened to
his daughter because she's all beat up
and scarred up and he's like she won't
talk about it and then he's the guy the
dad goes I got half a mind to wait out
in front of that Courthouse with a
shotgun then uh Jamie Dutton the
character says you don't need to do that
and he goes you don't tell me what I do
he's like I'll tell you what I'm going
to do a father should not have to and
then he goes I'm not telling you what to
do I'm saying you don't need to do that
and then he opens the trail and shows
him the blood and then the man looks at
him and says you should run for governor
it was amazing such a good scene you
should run for governor and then he was
like you did this for me and he's like I
did this forever any father who uh and
uh I was laughing my ass off at that and
he goes back in the day we would have
strung him up but this is he's like he's
like I could go to prison for telling
you this but I mean I'm imagining what
it must be like to be a dad
who you know and they show the scene and
his daughter there like the the
insinuation is that these two guys raped
her his daughter and beat the crap out
of her and then stole their horses and
then the commissioner got some Street
Justice for him and the guy cleans it
out and says I'll never say a word no
one will you have my word and then he
and then he says there will come a time
when you need a favor and I look forward
to giving it to you it's like a I kind
of feel like that's the energy Trump is
is hitting at but he's not getting there
you know what I mean like the energy of
a father whose daughter is mercilessly
beaten and raped and a man saying you
know these men it will no longer be a
problem I'm not a fan of the death
penalty but it's a powerful scene right
Trump's not getting that level of like a
man protecting his children you know
what I mean you could find some genuine
empathy for us for someone in that
position but this seems like a cartoon
exactly exactly it's a little over the
top yeah really good scene I think that
show's good I don't know people are
ragging on it why are they ragging on it
it's like woke now or something
I heard someone talking about a scene
recently where there was someone
reprimanding a guy for being a white guy
or something like that there's one
character that carries that kind of
storyline but generally I think the show
is extremely well written and I think it
handles uh sort of the challenges of
Rural America
in in a really interesting way
especially for an industry that's dying
with cattle industry yeah yeah it's
gorgeous to watch yeah I think that
show's pretty good yeah I like it but I
guess if they were saying for a while
that it was anti-woke now they're saying
it is woke I guess I don't know like I
said I don't watch it but I I heard on
the drive-in today I don't remember what
I was listening to but someone was
talking about uh about the show and
there was a character that essentially
it was the
it was about the character was talking
to a woman and she was saying that he
was somehow bad because he was a white
guy or something there's there's one
character the the daughter-in-law is
Native American and her family's not
like she's super Christian she's super
woke but she does have she like develops
a really interesting relationship with
the patriarch of the family and there's
respect there so I I could understand
like in this day and age you have to
have something in the storyline and I
think again even if you have to insert
this kind of ideology they handle it
enough I just interesting way I think
that's the energy Trump's trying to go
at you know we're going to string them
up we're going to get them and and there
may be a lot of dads who lost daughters
and sons because of fentanyl because of
these drugs and they're hearing Trump
say this and they're looking at him
saying you should run for president yeah
I mean I when I hear that kind of stuff
I I forget that he does speak in
extremely aggressive and authoritarian
terms when it comes to drug uh when it
comes to drugs so it maybe it was in
that context and
e as much as that is still hyperbolic
uh to to discuss that topic like that I
do understand that there are a lot of
people that are far more forgiving about
that kind of
kind of discourse when you're dealing
with drug dealers especially when it's
people that have lost family members and
there's a lot of people that have lost
family I know a lot of very very
well-mannered people through just
through my lines of work I used to work
for CBS I was a substance abuse
counselor I know a lot of people who are
extremely nice extremely polite you know
they're the kind of people that take
spiders out of the house and let it go
in the yard but they have family members
they have former Sons daughters that
have died and they said they'd see a
bullet between their eyes before
anything else
so this kind of thing does rile up
people and so if that was what he was
trying to to capture I guess I can
understand it he just did it in the the
Trump hyperbolic yeah almost Authority
kind of way I'm also watching another
show called The Last of Us have you guys
seen that one played the game years and
years ago but latest episode is uh
spoilers they're in Kansas City and the
federal government which created
quarantine zones in this location was
torturing raping and murdering people So
eventually a resistance forms a
revolution happens and then they kill
the all the federal agents but then they
become merciless death squads they just
kill anybody who collaborated they're
hunting them down and that's we don't
want that kind of that you don't want it
that's what happens we need rule of law
we need that's why when someone gets is
someone there's evidence someone
committed a crime you don't just string
them up you bring them before the court
you prove to the people and you show
that we have to maintain that order
otherwise it's chaos and then what
happens the Zombies come out of the
ground and eat them all and that's what
happens that you've been warned but the
thing is like you the to your point like
that's why we have the story or that's
why the the story of of John Adams
defending the uh the guys that carried
out the Boston Massacre is so impactful
and it's such an important story in
American history like that showed that
that was demonstrating liberal values
that the innocence of innocent people is
more important than Vengeance of angry
people and and it was you know the the
British weren't popular at that time and
and for John Adams to stand up and and
not only defend them but to to prove
that they were innocent you know that
that was a big deal and that's why I
think stories like that are super
important for for us to keep telling
people and I I feel like that kind of
stuff isn't taught in school the way
that it the way that it should be
anymore no they're just doing that oh
man I mean the proud family is worse
than people realize there's there's
there's another clip from the show we
talked about uh the new Disney prod
family where it's like slaves built this
country and because they have like a
woke teacher I guess then there's a
story about how this this girl's gay
interracial dads are fighting because
the black dad calls the white dad
fragile then there's another scene
apparently where riot police show up and
start lining up in front of these little
girls who are chanting why are you in
riot gear I don't see no riot here and
I'm just like man they are really laying
the propaganda on anything for these
kids it's all teaching negative
pessimistic perspectives not there is
nothing about that that is a positive
perspective it teaches a negative
outlook on America and a negative
outlook on on police it teaches nothing
it's all negativity and and you know we
just thought we were just talking about
the the
the Boston Massacre which is a a an
uplifting and positive story right they
were the Boston Massacre was terrible
but there was still the the liberal
ideas and principles that our country is
founded on they won the day and the
right thing happened innocent people
were set free and it's it's it's really
bad that stories about America nowadays
generally have a negative connotation or
context when it comes to you know an
educational uh in an education context
they don't it's almost as if you don't
hear positive stories about America
anymore and that is one of the most
detrimental things to to the United
States overall because why would anybody
want to defend something that they hate
right I think we we're systematically
programming our kids to not want to be
American when that's exactly what the
opposite of what this country needs
right now like if you were really trying
to make this country United and strong
and have people understand each other
better why would you be profiting off of
sowing seeds of Discord and negativity I
mean with the proud family example we
talked about this like what is the
message to this child if apparently her
interracial dads can't even see eye to
eye on Race they can't have a healthy or
productive conversation about it I think
it is really difficult to expect
militaries to be able to reach
recruiting requirements sure if number
one we have a very limited population of
those who qualify and on top of that
they're like well what's the point
what's the point of any of this I mean
that kind of uh Bleak future I mean we
can laugh about it on the show but to be
14 15 16 17 years old right now and
trying to decide like what am I going to
do with my life you can see why people
start to think they don't matter and
nothing they do will be able to save
anyone from the terrible consequences
that a lot of people face right now I
don't think that we are uh encouraging
people to be aspirational because
ultimately people feel like they get a
better reaction out of negativity they
get more attention for screaming about
what's wrong than trying to promote
what's good thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time